now following the lead of the florida
state senate the florida house today
they passed a bill stripping disney of
its self-governing status it now goes to
governor ron desantis desantis desk to
be signed into law disney along with
their allies and the media has continued
to amplify lies about florida's new
parental rights law just listen to
msdnc's nicole wallace actually
comparing ron desantis his policies to
russian soldiers raping children this is
nbc news take a look
i worry that in covering glenn yunken
and his politics of parental choice all
the focus was on how well it worked and
even in our conversations about desantis
it's about how well they're serving him
the the truth is
dehumanization
as a tactic for politics is from war
dehumanization is a it's a it's a tactic
it's being used right now the russians
get their soldiers
to rape children by dehumanizing them
dehumanization as a practice is a tactic
of war it's being deployed in our
politics
here to explain florida attorney general
ashley moody um
madam attorney general uh can you make
that connection for me because i can't
quite get it
you know who's dehumanizing who
i mean you have the media perpetuating
this big farce about a bill in florida
that is meant to protect children as
young as four and five years old
from classroom instruction on
sexual interests
it's
incredible that you have
the media disney coming back and saying
they're gonna they're gonna work
vigorously to repeal it i mean what does
that mean disney wants classroom
instruction on sexual orientation for
children as young as four
i mean it's incredible sean and what's
going on
is it is becoming apparent that
those in this administration and in
leadership cannot lead on the economy on
energy on crime on the border and so
they have to throw up this big emotional
mushroom cloud calling people's names
calling republican leaders that are
trying to protect children comparing
them to russians that rape children it's
incredible they're dehumanizing an
entire leadership in florida it's
unacceptable
i have the solution let parents do their
job instill values in their kids and
they stick to reading writing math
science and computers and the problem
solved thank you for being with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else